technology has made it easier for
parents to snoop on their children a
study found 61% of parents check their
teens web history 60% monitor their
social media use and 48% have looked
through their child's phone calls and
messages psychologists and CBS News
contributor listen to more writes about
this in her latest New York Times online
article is snooping on teenagers ever ok
Lisa is also the author of untangled
guiding teenage girls through 7 the 7
transitions into adulthood
Elysa good morning good morning so are
there some instances where it's okay to
snoop well first let's say what snooping
is right it's monitoring without telling
them you're monitoring so it's going on
under the table so already we are
starting to compromise questions of
trust so we want to be really careful if
we think about snooping
because when parents do it we have
research showing that it does harm the
relationship with their kids so how do
they don't know you're snooping the
question of what do you do if you find
something well hello my name is Gail I
was a Snooper because they want privacy
doesn't mean they're doing anything
because most of the stuff I found was
quite boring well that's a really
important Agers want privacy for its own
sake and just because a teenager wants
privacy doesn't mean they're up to
something and I think it's important for
parents to remember that right there's
any other way to accomplish the
interests of the parents without
snooping absolutely the research also
tells us they should probably just ask
we have research showing that teenagers
do expect to share information with
their parents especially around health
and safety we also know that teenagers
share more information with parents that
they feel accept them and trust them so
if parents say look this is not about
you getting in trouble this is not about
me getting mad we want to know that
you're okay and you can tell me anything
and you can tell me anything this is
about safety chances are they're going
to get an above board response that they
can really work with we've been talking
all morning promoting your
your appearance about legal issues with
snoot yes they're very very murky but
here's what we know you do have a right
to spy on your own child that does not
always extend to a right to spy on other
people's kids which if you're monitoring
a conversation that could easily happen
hmm
so what are the legal issues you know it
gets tricky fast but I think parents
just want to be mindful that they may
actually end up monitoring a
conversation about somebody else's kid
or involving somebody else's kid and not
all parents may be okay with their child
being spied on okay and I also think
it's important for a point out snooping
this comes from a protective and loving
yes it always starts from a loving space
right another thing that's interesting
in the research is that parents who have
snoop don't have kids who are be
misbehaving more yeah we find that too
yeah I agree
thank you Lisa do more thank you very
much Lisa's book as norm mentioned is
called untangled it's out in paperback
right now wherever you like to buy your
books